what caused a 330 billion dollar company
to be bought for 1.9 billion well let me
make a um
a comment around around the loans again
so when we make a uh and again
i've got a i'm just going to do the
whole portfolio and then we can
go from there just to give you a couple
of numbers if you take all the uh we
call them option armed loans that we had
made uh they had a loan to value ratio
that averaged about 70 percent
and um and that was the entire portfolio
including the new originations and and
and the like yeah again think about
making a loan that 70 percent loan to
value and with negative am
amortization for the entire portfolio it
took it up to maybe 71
so still should have been a very
conservative loan to value ratio
and what really hit everything is is a
couple things one is housing prices when
they started falling fell so fast and so
quickly that that caused people's
behavior to make payments the likes
start to change too
because if you drop housing prices 30 or
40 percent guess what people just
stopped making their mortgage payments
because they don't have any equity in
their home anymore so that's factor
number one the second that's really um
that really changed that product in a
negative way was the government and what
happened is that product was started as
i said by companies like golden west and
then a couple of companies that we
acquired three companies we acquired in
california which were uh great western
hf amundsen and american savings were
all large uh option arm originators and
that's why we how we became a major
player in that
those were good products when they were
all originated for portfolio
so we all kind of knew and underwrote
them to be careful
now what happened in beginning in about
2000 2001
the government said that's such a good
deal we want fannie mae and freddie mac
to start purchasing these so they
started setting the underwriting
standards nationally for that product
and then as soon as they did that then
that brought a bunch of mortgage bankers
in
brokers like countrywide who was not
doing them for portfolio and they're
just going to underwrite to whatever
standards fannie and freddie did and the
quality of that product plummeted
now
we recognize that as a problem
so i cut our loan originations from 19
from 2003
to 2007 by 74 percent
imagine running your business and one of
your key things
and and we became very concerned about
housing about what was happening to that
product so i cut our product lines by 74
of all residential lending which was got
criticized like heck from wall street
saying how can you run a business
cutting a key product by 74 you know
you're going to cut you know that's not
the right thing to do for a growth
company i said we're going to try that
you know we got to because we think the
product's getting riskier and you're
right so it ended up blowing up
uh more than it ever should have and i
think that a key part of that was
uh that product becoming nationalized
with fannie and freddie setting the
underwriting standards and that product
was always designed to be a product for
portfolio
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]